candid
truth what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at candid truth we're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it tonight we're
going to talk about Wicked I didn't even
want to touch this movie because there's
just so much out there already about how
weird they're acting and how they're
crying at every interview and about some
of the agendas that are wrapped up in
there but I couldn't avoid what I was
seeing when I saw the trailer finally
and what the message was clear to me
because spiritual things are spiritually
discerned and when when God knocks the
blinders off your eyes you can no longer
see the world the same that's why we got
the intro where he's putting on the
glasses and he's seeing things different
because that's the way God has allowed
me to see the world now he's given me
the gift of discernment and I'm not
saying that to brag in any way I used to
be as blind as everyone else even as a
Christian I was one of those Christians
that couldn't tell that Harry Potter was
pushing witchcraft now I'm like whoa how
was I missing something that was so
obvious but now I want to look at this
movie
Wicked so the movie is title alone
Wicked why are we why would any
Christian go to see a movie called
wicked it seems like Christianity has
lost all discernment we're watching
shows called Lucifer and we're just
watching all the entertainment of the
world and what Satan is great at Satan
is so good at messing with your
heartstrings messing with your emotions
and he can get you wrapped up if you say
hey that movie really has a a subtle
message in there an attack on God an
attack on God's government people always
come at you and say no no you missed the
whole point the point was about
creativity or about racism or this and
that that's what propaganda is you can't
just put out a message that says hey we
hate God and he's a tyrannical villain
you have to wrap it up in something
that's palatable for the masses and most
people are not going to watch something
that's blatantly occult and I take that
back that's the way the mindset was 20
years ago now I'm just mindblown because
now Satan doesn't even have to hide for
instance in the anime World there used
to be a lot of subliminal messages in
shows like Dragon Ball Z you're talking
about these uh Heroes that were worship
a dragon that grants you wishes and the
Bible calls the dragon Satan but now
there's an anime called the seven deadly
sins who are the heroes and they're
fighting against the Ten Commandments
and nobody bats than I like nobody even
thinks like this is a blatant satanic
attack on God and His government and his
Ten Commandments it's mind-blowing the
same message over and over and over if
you guys aren't familiar with little
light Studios I worked there for seven
years Aubrey worked there and this
message has been shown over and over and
over again you can no longer call it a
coincidence how much longer can you call
something a coincidence that has a
pattern patterns mean something all
right I don't want to lose you guys I'm
going to get into this wicked look at
the title we're going to look at the
trailer a quick chopped up version of
the trailer I want you to pay attention
to certain things because there's
mention of are we born Wicked or is it
put upon us so think about that the the
idea of being born this way or are
people and their actions causing you to
become Wicked so putting the blame on
someone else instead of yourself are we
in control of our own lives do we make
our own free will choices do we have
control over how we turn out yes in some
way yes we can suffer through things and
go through trauma and things like that
but Christ can set us free from all of
this so that's what they say in the in
the beginning um are we born Wicked or
is it put upon us then you'll see um
mention of well first you'll see a goat
a talking goat that's a teacher and at
this like witchcraft school I'm getting
all this from the trailer so maybe I'm
I'm wrong on some of this stuff and the
wicked witch the green witch who was
wicked Remember The Wizard of Oz there
was a good witch which is no such thing
there's no such thing as a good witch
but either way in The Wizard of Oz there
was a good versus an evil and the whole
idea was good is good and bad is bad but
in here the tables are turned and so the
wicked witch you'll find out she's the
one that has power and that The Wizard
of Oz he has no power and he actually
needs help from the witch because he's
weak check this out are people born
Wicked or do they have wickedness thrust
upon them please everyone take your seat
that was you who made all that happen
how did you do it you're the one the
wizard has been waiting for something
has changed within me something's
changed in
me the wonderful Wizard of O summons you
to the Emerald City come with me what to
meet the
wizard I am as the great and terrible
something bad is happening in
ours you have no real power that's why I
need
you I'm not afraid it's the wizard who
should be afraid of
me I'm not afraid it's the wizard who
should be afraid of me if you know the
storyline of The Wizard of Oz the wizard
is like God he's like this all knowing
being that is in the emerald palace with
a yellow brick road that leads to him
these are all key phrases to listen for
and we're we're going to go through it
I'm going to show you step by step every
little detail of this thing I couldn't
believe it my mind was blown but notice
the talking goat the the wicked witch
who she's the one that has the power he
she pointed out to the wizard you don't
have any power and he said that's why I
need you see now it's no God I need the
wicked witch I need the wicked
witchcraft who is this wicked witch
let's go into
this so
Alaba trope also known as the Wicked
Witch of the West is the green skinn
protagonist protagonist means good guy
she's the good guy okay protagonist of
wicked I don't know why oh Wicked the
movie The Life and Times of the Wicked
Witch of the West published in 1995 the
Wicked Witch of the West was originally
an antagonist Bad Guy created by author
L frank Bal from his 1900
children's novel The Wonderful Wizard of
Oz and notably in the 1939 MGM musical
film version of The Wizard of Oz so
already off the bat we see that the
wicked witch was an antagonist she was
evil and wicked in the original but now
in this movie The Wicked she's a
protagonist so already I'm getting Vibes
of the Bible verse Isaiah 5:20 that says
woe unto them that call evil good and
good evil that put Darkness for light
and light for darkness that put bitter
for sweet and Sweet for bitter this has
been going on for a couple of years this
is just four examples but movies have
been coming out lately that give you a
Sympathy for the Devil message a
Sympathy for the Devil gospel Joker we
know that joker is this sadistic Maniac
killer and yet in the movie The Joker I
never even saw any of these movies but
what I gathered from reading the fan
stuff and all that the Joker was about
no he couldn't help it he was bullied he
was pushed into this he was pushed into
killing hundreds of people and being a
sadistic Maniac Corella same thing
Sympathy for the Devil Corella cruel
devil Corella devil manif Maleficent
Maleficent she is the wicked Queen but
in this movie no sympathize with her
because when she was a little girl she
was made fun of and wicked same thing
Satan knows how to put his message in a
pretty little package that you'll accept
and it breaks my heart I was going
through this stuff and I was literally
crying looking at this stuff because I
was thinking about how deceived the
world is to we live in a world where now
Satan doesn't even have to hide anymore
and we eat it up and we go and pay we
throw money at it and watch it and put
Satan's gospel in our minds and
entertain ourselves with this wickedness
literally the movie called wicked it's
insane so look at some of the
merchandise here we got don't hide your
magic this is a t-shirt that anybody can
buy children adults everything don't
hide your magic and Magic the definition
is the power of apparently influencing
the course of events by using mysterious
and Supernatural forces
that's witchcraft notice at the bottom
it even says similar sorcery witchcraft
Wizardry necromancy enchantment and
Revelation 221 14-15 we don't have to be
confused or deceived about these topics
the Bible is super clear revelation 22
it says blessed are they that do his
Commandments that they may have right to
the tree of life and may enter into in
through the gates into the city those
who do those who do his
Commandments think about that Lawless
one the Lawless one is coming he is the
Antichrist the Beast system and those
who keep the Commandments meaning
lawkeepers not lawlessness but
lawkeepers they have right to the tree
of life and the message we get over and
over and over from Hollywood is Break
The Rules follow your heart do what thou
Wilt if it feels good do it it's the
same message over and over for without
meaning without the city with outside
the gates of Heaven are dogs and
Sorcerers notice another word for magic
is sorcerer Sorcerers and whoremongers
and murderers and idolators and
whosoever loveth and maketh a lie
sorcery is on the same exact level as a
murderer and an idolator and a liar then
it goes on there's more
Deuteronomy 1810 through2 covers the
other listed words there witchcraft
Wizardry necromancy enchantment it says
there shall not be found among you any
one that maketh his son or his daughter
to pass through the fire or that useth
divination or an observer of times or an
enchanter or a witch or a charmer or a
consulter with familiar spirits or a
wizard or a necromancer for all that do
these things are an Abomination unto the
Lord every single word that describes
the word
magic is in the Bible and it's called an
Abomination and you will not be in the
Kingdom of Heaven there was so much to
include in this presentation that I
forgot certain verses but in Romans I
think it's Romans
4:32 I think I think that's the verse
but it says not only those who do the
wicked acts are worthy of death but
those who take pleasure in them that do
them meaning you don't have to be a
witch to be as guilty as the witch if
you are being being Bewitched by it if
you are being entertained by watching
Witchcraft and sorcery on the screen
you're as guilty as the witch because
you're being entertained by
wickedness taking pleasure in
unrighteousness That's what Satan has
been doing to us for years and years and
years making his message and sin and
wickedness on every level look glamorous
and
fun defy this is a wicked shirt that
simply just says defy and the definition
of defy literally is openly resist or
refuse to obey what did we just see in
that verse it said those who do his
Commandments have right to the tree of
life and those who don't have right to
the Tree of Life are those who defy
those who resist to refuse to
obey AKA rebellion and what does the
Bible say about rebellion it says for
Rebellion is as the sin of Witchcraft
it's the same thing we're talking about
witchcraft here rebellion and Witchcraft
combined and stubbornness is as iniquity
and idolatry because thou H has rejected
the word of the Lord he hath also
rejected thee from being King look if
you resist or in this sense defy against
God's Commandments you will not inherit
the kingdom of God and you might think
no I love God and I do obey and all
these things but this movie and many
many many others uncountable movies all
have the same message you're going to
see it over and over how long will it
take before those seeds start to take
root what about the youth who have grown
up on this message their entire life do
what you want resist go against the all
powerful being who has rules so many
movies have this defy gravity is another
shirt here
and what is gravity it says gravity is
considered a law of physics so it
literally says defy laws defy the law I
think it's interesting that this hat
maybe this is a stretch I'll I'll admit
but that hat looks a lot like the Tower
of Babel and they were all about
rebellion and Defiance maybe that's a
stretch but either way defy means to
rebel and gravity is a law and if you
are putting a message out there like
this you're saying defy the laws Rebel
the law Screen Rant said the Wicked
Witch of the West flying on her broom is
a memorable image of The Wizard of Oz
and wicked found a way to add profound
meaning to this
retroactively Defying Gravity
retroactively okay they found a profound
meaning to this
retroactively Defying Gravity that's the
name of a song Defying Gravity speaks to
anyone who has ever been made to feel
they are the enemy trapped on the
outside of accepted Society alaba's
words send a message to members of the
lgbtq plus Community the disabled
Community immigrants underdogs and
anyone else who fits within the category
of other the wizard was disingenuous
when he said everyone deserves a chance
to fly but alphaba took his words in
Wicked and organically delivered them to
anyone and everyone who needed to hear
them notice what it says it wraps up
something like
lgbtq and puts that on the same playing
field as being disabled or an immigrant
or an underdog they're apples and
bananas you cannot compare apples to
oranges
here this is what Satan's always doing
he's always trying to say oh if you go
against this minority Community that's
the same as being a slave owner how are
you going to wrap up race in a in a
lifestyle that you choose that's in
Disobedience to God willful Disobedience
to God and this is how he does it so
wrapping up this community with disabled
and immigrants and underdogs it's not
even true but notice it's talking about
Defying Gravity this song defy gravity
speaks to those people so let let's
check it out and a shirt like this
wicked on a young girl these these
shirts you can find them in the
children's section and this girl's just
just wearing a shirt that says Wicked
and on the back it says defy gravity 10
years ago or more when I was growing up
as a teenager this is the type of merch
that was out there from Hot Topic and
places like that if your daughter was N9
years old 10 11 12 if your pre-teen
daughter came in the house wearing this
shirt how would you feel you'd say take
that off you're not Wicked get that off
your body but when it's in this package
here because they made a movie off of it
it's acceptable oh you can throw some
pink and green in there and now it's
really acceptable Wicked oh that's that
beautiful movie takes me back to The
Wizard of Oz when I was a kid it's all
about
Nostalgia Satan loves wrapping his
message up in Nostalgia that plays with
your heartstrings changed for good you
are changed for Life by wickedness
they're telling you right here on the
shirt when you become Wicked you're
changed for good there's a line in the
sand yes there's time to repent but you
don't want to play around with sin
Wicked change for good Pink goes good
with green this is what I really started
digging into why pink and why green why
are these two colors being put together
and they're literally saying Pink goes
good with
green Remember The Wizard of Oz was
about good versus evil good witch which
you know there's no such thing but good
versus evil now it says pink which is
the good witch and green which is the
bad witch go good together what are we
doing here we're combining these things
I want to show you what pink and green
mean in the occult World divine feminine
due to its association with softness and
tenderness pink is often linked to the
divine feminine aspect and spirituality
so okay so pink we're talking about the
divine feminine and now green which is
about nature grow rebirth renewal we're
talking about the Phoenix out of the
ashes we've talked about that before on
this show and down here it says Earth
Magic so sorcery divine feminine and
sorcery but when you look into the age
of Aquarius what is the age of Aquarius
it started sometime in 2020 2021 people
have uh a difference of opinion on when
it started but look what it says the age
of Aquarius is a period of time
associated with the zodiac sign Aquarius
and is believed to to bring an increase
in harmony to the world some say the age
of Aquarius is also the return of the
divine feminine who is reclaiming her
power truth and
innocence now we know now we know why
pink and green are together because in
this time that we live in with the whole
climate agenda and this whole feminist
movement we know that the future of this
world is a combination of the divine
feminine and the green movement pink and
green together it's another subliminal
subtle way to push this idea onto the
world that we're going into the age of
Aquarius so here you see a combination
again the green hand and the pink hand
together because hey good and evil need
to go together right and they're per and
they're making the W for Wicked but
they're they're coming together this is
no longer about good versus evil here
you see it again the evil and the good
are coming together to make the W to
spell
Wicked here you see them clasping hands
and you notice everything on the left
side is dead and dark and everything on
the right side the sun is rising and
this pink and flowering and they're
holding hands because they're joining
together the one on the left has a scow
and the one on the right has a smile but
when they come together it's perfect
Unity notice even the logo is half pink
and half green because it's not about
good versus evil anymore it's about
merging good and evil what do you think
when you see this image right here it
says everyone deserves a chance to fly
are you seeing this picture in your mind
because I was and who's at the top God
reaching out to Adam but in this picture
we see that the good which is Adam and
the bad wi is replacing God wasn't it's
Satan that said I will Ascend my Throne
higher than the heights of the Stars I
will be like the most high right Satan
wants to take the place of
God and so that's exactly what's
happening here because this good witch
is in fact Satan in the story here you
see that the old poster before this was
a movie when it was just a musical
they're blatantly showing you the black
and the white it's not green and pink
it's black and white because this is the
yin-yang philosoph and if you know what
that means it's talking about the
balance of Good and Evil combining good
and evil together but what does the
Bible say about Good and Evil Duality
talking about Duality the quality or
state of having two different opposite
parts or elements dualism this is
satanic don't be fooled by oh there's a
little bit there's always a little bit
of good A little bit of bad as long as
it's balance no that's satanic 2
Corinthians 6:14 says be ye not
unequally yolked together with
unbelievers for what Fellowship hath
righteousness with unrighteousness and
what communion hath light with
Darkness this is the truth the truth
will set you free do not as children of
the light do not mingle with the
Darkness Darkness and Light do not go
together you cannot put dark and light
together and have a balance of Good and
Evil that's Satan's message here you'll
see that there's the bad witch on the
left and the the good Wi on the right
but they both say what at the bottom
Wicked so now it's not about good versus
evil it's we're both Wicked whether
you're good or bad you're Wicked Embrace
The Darkness Be
Wicked if you saw a movie like this you
would never let your child go see it the
wicked you would never let your child go
see this movie and yet when it comes in
this pretty little princess package
Wicked oh it's pink look at the smile on
her face as she's doing an enchantment
with a spell book under her arms a
witchcraft spell
book this is insane Satan doesn't even
have to hide anymore this breaks my
heart because this is the same as
showing baffet as a
cartoon if you take something satanic
and make it cute and
colorful and kids are drawn to it that
is satanic that's propaganda and it's no
different when you see this book that
says Wicked and has the wicked witch on
it it's the same thing now what is this
green City that we see it's called
Emerald
City and Revelation 4:3 says and he that
sat was to look upon like Jasper and a
sard sardine stone sarden stone sorry if
I get that wrong and there was a rainbow
round about the throne in the sight unto
a an emerald so Revelation 4:3 says that
God's Throne is like Emerald with a
rainbow around it look at the picture of
The Wizard of Oz of this Emerald City
with a rainbow around it is this a
coincidence again the rainbow around the
Emerald City you guys tell me is this a
reach I mean everything's adding up here
you're going to see more and more
everything adds up the Emerald City with
a rainbow around
it so Follow The Yellow Brick Road well
you know the Bible talks about golden
streets in heaven right that lead to God
but it's yellow they're Yellow Brick
Road they're not gold is this a reach I
looked it up in the wonderful Wizard of
Oz the yellow brick road symbolizes the
gold standard so the road that's yellow
is literally gold we're talking about
Golden Street
that lead to an emerald city that has a
rainbow around it that's not a
coincidence so here what it says in
Isaiah 40:22 it says he sits enthroned
above the circle of the earth and its
people are like grasshoppers he
stretches out the heavens like a canopy
and spreads them out like a tent to live
in now I don't want people to get
triggered because of the shape of the
Earth this is actually the top of a
globe but notice what's on top it is the
North Pole and even on the other map
it's the North Pole right there in the
center if he sits on top of the circle
wouldn't it make sense that he's right
in the center right he's directly above
the center of the circle as he looks
down and so when you look up NASA
Polaris there's a star named Polaris
that's directly above the North Pole it
says Polaris appears very close to the
spot in the sky where Earth's access of
rotation points Polaris known as the
North Star sits more or less directly
above Earth's north
pole are you catching this directly
above the
Earth over the North Pole the center of
the Earth Map is the is the Northern
Star Polaris
and the Bible says that God sits
above the Earth the circle of the earth
looking down and his throne is like
Emerald with a
rainbow have you ever noticed in the
North Pole there is emerald and a
rainbow he sat
upon and he that sat was to look upon
like Jasper and the sarden stone and
there was a rainbow and round about the
throne in a sight like unto an emerald
Revelation 4:3 what does this have to do
with the Wizard of Oz you might
ask because I'm trying to make a point
that the wizard is God he lives in a
emerald Palace in the center of the map
of
Earth and when you check this
out the old maps of Earth this is not
some conspiracy theory look this up look
up maps that contain the Garden of Eden
right there in the center is the Garden
of Eden these are the four rivers that
flow out from Eden that's the the stone
in the middle that's the emerald Kingdom
well that's the that's the Garden of
Eden so in the center right above the
center is where God is and look at the
map look at the map of The Marvelous map
of Oz what is in the center the Emerald
City this is where God is this is where
the golden streets are and they even
show it when they do the the live
musical performances they show this on a
big LED screen and look how it's glowing
the emerald is glowing from the center
and it looks just like the Northern
Lights so this is building a case here
who is The Wizard of Oz I believe
without a doubt he's
God one of the former Kings of Oz was
named
Pastoria so even one of the former Kings
was named Pastor that all the more makes
me believe that he is a religious figure
a Godlike
figure so let's read about oz in the
movie or in the musical and in the novel
Wicked how do how do they portray the
wizard it says with the wizard as ruler
everything is drastically changing as Oz
is becoming segregated and racist
especially between the people and
talking animals who once lived
comfortably hand in hand in Oz now
animals are being treated poorly due to
the Wizard's government system which has
created a structure for Oz that
parallels the events of the Nazi Germans
Nazi Germany's Holly
cost it says that the Wizards government
parallels the Nazi Germany's Holocaust
and the turmoil of the Great Depression
do you see the propag Anda
here God in the Emerald City in the
center of Earth's map with a golden
street that goes to it the all great and
terrible Oz Wizard of Oz has a
government that's comparable to Nazi
Germany do you see
it it says again it says after this
alphaba takes Glenda and goes to Oz's
imperial capital called The Emerald City
to show dilan's work to to the wizard
after a disappointing meeting she Parts
ways with Glenda telling her she will
not return to Craig Hall and later
becomes a member of the resistance
against the wizard and his Prejudice
laws do you see this who formed a
resistance against God in heaven that
was none other than
Satan if Satan formed a resistance
against the government of
God and the evil witch the wicked witch
Alaba had a disappointing meeting with
the wizard and she forms a resistance
against the wizard what is the parallel
here the parallel is that alphaba is
Satan and she's forming a resistance
against the wizard who is God that's
what the whole story line is about
fighting against God a message that we
see over and over and over if you
haven't seen this stuff please go check
out some little light Studios videos
because over and over the movie about
the Matrix was the same thing it was
about waking up from the system of rules
and saying I don't need you when he
talked on the phone booth I don't need
you I'm going to show a world without
rules and without governments and
without this and that the movie
smallfoot The stonekeeper wore all the
laws written in stone as a robe and his
daughter started a resistance against
him saying that he's a liar
coincidentally alphaba this wicked witch
is the daughter of the wizard go
figure the the Star Wars saga same thing
the son of Darth Vader Darth Vader whose
father vodder who has this regime of
everybody's in perfect white order and
he was born without a father and he was
the chosen one and he wears a chest
plate with these colored buttons on it
that look like the ephod that the priest
wears He's the bad guy and the good guy
is named Luke which means light or the
lightbearer and he finds out that this
voder is his
father Satan's father is God and Satan
formed a resistance a rebellion against
God in
heaven so let's check it out
because we see here that even the wizard
himself is wearing green emerald if you
will on his outfit and Alaba literally
is the daughter of the wizard she finds
out spoiler alert sorry but I want to
read the lyrics of defy gravity because
that wasn't just a t-shirt it's a song
and Satan loves to use
music music is so powerful do you know
what they call those earworms like you
you get a song stuck in your head you
can't get it out it happens to me all
the time even with music that I hate
gets stuck in my head music is powerful
Satan knows this and he's putting his
message in these beautiful Melodies no
longer do you have to get a satanic
message through metal music now you get
it through Disney style music and this
song does sound amazing and beautiful
and uplifting and empowering and what
are the
lyrics it
says alphab why couldn't you have stayed
calm for once instead of flying off the
handle I hope you're happy I hope you're
happy now and this is the important part
that's underline I hope you're happy how
you've hurt your cause
forever think about it has Satan hurt
his cause
forever yes Satan no longer has a chance
to repent he once had that chance God
will always give anyone a chance to
repent but Satan has went too far and he
no longer has a chance to repent that's
why all these messages come out about
Sympathy for the Devil because one day
when God says this is my child and he is
worthy to come into my kingdom Satan
will say well what about me he's a
sinner like I am and so Satan's whole
argument will be well you're saving all
these Sinners what about me I'm just a
sinner like them but he never repented
and he went too far and it says right
here I hope you're happy now you've hurt
your cause
forever the next line says Elfie listen
to me just say you're sorry you can
still be with the wizard
look if you just repent if you just say
I'm sorry and turn from your wicked ways
you can still be with the wizard it's
showing his mercy and Grace here what
you've worked and waited for you can
have all you ever wanted and I think
this is the witch saying I know so she's
saying I know I can have that but just
like Satan she's saying I will not but I
don't want to no I can't want it anymore
that's what the wicked which just saying
I don't care if I could say sorry and be
with the wizard in the perfect Kingdom
again I don't want it and I can't want
it anymore something has changed within
me something is not the same that's what
the Bible says that when Pride you were
perfect in your ways about Satan about
Lucifer you were perfect in your ways
since the day I created you until
iniquity came up in you Pride was
Satan's
fall I'm through with playing by the
rules of someone else's game oh my
goodness it's the same message over and
over and over are we even surprised
anymore another movie about I'm done
with the rules sick of the rules too
late for second guessing too late to go
back to sleep because if you follow the
rules you're sleeping you need to wake
up you need to wake up and break free
from these rules it's time to trust my
instincts close my eyes and leap isn't
this the same message from
Frozen no right no wrong no rules for me
I'm
free let it go take a leap isn't it the
exact same
story she's saying I'm done with the
rules I'm not second guessing I'm not
I'm I'm never going back it's time to
trust my heart my instincts close my
eyes and leap or let it go right it's
time to try Defying Gravity it's time
for me to rebel against the law the laws
of nature that God has created I'm going
to
rebel I think I'll try to define gravity
and you can't pull me down she's talking
directly to the wizard when she's saying
this stuff I saw the scene from the
music video and she was saying no wizard
can pull me down I don't care who you
are she says I'm through accepting
limits I don't accept limits anymore cuz
someone's because or because someone
says they're so just because someone
says there's rules I refuse to follow
them I'm not accepting them anymore some
things I cannot change but I'll try I'll
never or but till I try I'll never
know unless I try some things I can't
change God's rules will never change
they're written in stone they're written
in our hearts they're in eternity
and this is the words of Satan some
things I cannot change but till I try
I'll never know you know the angels in
heaven have free will they could turn
and resist against God at any moment but
they're seeing what is happening when
you live in a world without rules the
pain the misery the chaos in this world
is because of the choices we're making
to rebel against God that's the way it
was in the kingdom of heaven when they
lived in a perfect world with God Alone
Satan said I might not be able to change
him but unless I try I'll never
know it says too long I've been afraid
of losing love I guess I've
lost well if that's love it comes at
much too high a
cost isn't God love God is love and she
says if that's love it comes at too high
a cost I don't want it I'm defying it
well if that's love it comes at much too
high a
cost think of what we could do together
this is what the good witch and the bad
witch are saying I think the good witch
is speaking here actually the bad witch
is saying Glenda come with me the wicked
witch is calling the good witch Glenda
come with me think of what we could do
together let's unite pink and green go
together right
unlimited there's nothing we can't do
the only time I think of this in the
Bible is in Genesis when they built that
Tower of Babel and God said when they
come together when they unite together
there's nothing that they can't do he
says and this they think to do this
wickedness when man comes together and
isn't scattered like he scattered them
there's nothing they can't do
unlimited together we're unlimited these
are the words of Babylon the Tower of
Babel together we're unlimited there's
nothing we can't do together we'll be
the greatest team there has ever been
that's exactly what the tower Babel said
we are the greatest we'll make this
Tower so great that everyone will know
that we're the
greatest Glenda dreams the way we pl
them if we work in tandem there's no
fight we cannot
win who's the fight against
in this story so far who was the
resistance against the wizard or God and
she's saying there's no fight we cannot
win if we just come together and that's
Satan's lie if we unite together coexist
if we put aside all our differences and
come together there's no fight that we
can't win this is the story of every
movie right now there's something coming
it's an asteroid it's an alien invasion
it's Thanos whatever it is we need to
put aside all our differences and come
together and fight against this one
tyrannical threat that's coming to Earth
but when you read Revelation or other
parts of Prophecy it says that Satan is
the one who's trying to save this world
from one threat that's coming and if
you're not on Christ's side you get to
be on that side you get to be in that
Army that's trying to fight against God
it's
insane and it goes on and says I hope
you're
happy now that you're choosing this
this I hope it brings you Bliss I really
hope you get it and you don't live to
regret it I hope you're happy in the end
I'm thinking the end of time when you
face that judgment I hope you're happy
in the end I hope you're happy my friend
I feel like this is how the Angels must
have felt when they see Satan turning
and that he was their friend he was
right next to Jesus in heaven he was was
so had such a high Authority that the
Bible calls him the covering cherub you
were the covering cherub and all the
other Angels were like I hope it's worth
it in the end I hope you find what
you're looking for I hope you're happy
my
friend and someone told me lately this
is the wicked witch speaking and someone
told me lately everyone deserves a
chance to
fly and if I'm flying solo at least I'm
flying free
and to those who ground me take a
message back from me this is Satan
speaking everyone deserves a chance to
fly Satan that's his message why can't I
fly up to you when you come in your
second coming why can't I go to meet you
in the air you said everyone gets a
chance because everyone does get a
chance if you repent and turn to God and
accept him and live by his ways then we
will get to be in that perfect Kingdom
and and she says if I'm flying solo
imagine That's what Satan said look I
I'm doing this even if I got to go alone
unfortunately he convin convinced a
third of the angels to go with him but
at least I'm flying free Freedom comes
from Christ the truth will set you free
who is the truth Christ is the truth how
does God speak through his word his word
is truth his laws are truth and the
Bible calls his Commandments the law of
Liberty because when you live according
to his laws you have true Freedom when
you don't lie don't steal don't cheat
don't commit adultery that's true
Freedom you live in a life where you're
not hurting yourself you're not hurting
others and you're not hurting God
Freedom true slavery is when you follow
your heart when you try to do it your
own way and that's what Satan's been
trying to do but he's packaging it up as
Freedom that's what Transformer's
message was
the cube that created all life and and
worlds is uh he said true Freedom comes
in destroying that Cube that created all
life and all the worlds that's crazy
that's Satan tell them how I'm Defying
Gravity look if somebody tries to ground
me take a message back and tell them how
I'm Defying Gravity tell them how I'm
rebelling God's laws I'm flying high
Defying Gravity and soon I'll match them
in renown I will Ascend my throne above
the heights of the clouds I will be like
the most high I will be renowned like
God and nobody in all of Oz no wizard
that there is or
was wow she's actually saying who is or
was she's dethroning him already no
wizard that is or was is ever going to
bring me down this is rebellion to the
highest power this is straight the words
of Satan from his own mouth this is his
song his
lyrics No One Mourns for the wicked she
says but what does Ezekiel 18:23
says have I any pleasure at all that the
wicked should die sayeth the Lord God
and not that he should return from his
ways and live God is begging for us to
turn from our Wicked ways and
live
repent but the message of this movie is
oh there's no mourning for the
wicked Ezekiel 3311 says say unto them
as I live saith the Lord God I have no
pleasure in the death of the wicked but
that the wicked turn from his ways and
live turn ye turn ye from your evil ways
for why will ye die oh House of Israel
the movie is called wicked and it's
saying turn from your evil
ways God is not a tyrannical villain
he's pleading with people turn from your
wicked ways and live he desires to give
us eternal life more than we can even
imagine it and this all came from this
novel called wicked the novel that was
turned into a musical and now turned
into a movie that is rated
PG the movie is rated p g all ages
Parental Guidance okay but they're
saying there's nothing in here that a
child can't watch without their parents
by their side all this stuff we've been
looking at is PG and it came from a book
called wicked and now they're
repackaging this book with the cover of
the PG movie remember the movie is is PG
we're going to wrap an old book in a PG
cover and guess what when kids love this
movie and their parents are encouraging
them why don't you read a book They're
gonna say Mom can I have this book
Wicked Ariana Grande and the movie that
I love sure I can't wait to buy you that
book and let you read it you won't
believe what's in this
book The Daily Telegraph says parents
warning over Wicked book ahead ahead of
movie release
ahead of the release of the highly
anticipated Wicked movie fans of the
original book are giving a warning to
parents about its content whilst the new
release like the musical is child
friendly and will be PG rated the book
features a host of mature themes with
Tori K camito from the the Oz Vlog on
Tik Tok among a host of other creators
deeming it inappropriate for readers
under the the age of
18 these people are saying look this
book is not suitable for anyone under 18
and now they're wrapping that book in
the cover of a PG movie how many kids
are going to read this
book holy smokes it's so adult
commenters on the original video share
their own personal an antidote of
reading the book at too young an age
reading Wicked too young is a Canon
event for theater kids one says I was 14
when my parents got it for me after I
became obsessed with the Broadway
musical said another 14-year-old me was
not prepared 14-year-old me was not
prepared what about the nine-year-old
what about the 10-year-old the book's
contents have been considered jarring
even by
adults I started reading Wicked this
month in prep of the movie and holy
smokes it's so adult a commenter said
do you see the problem here this wicked
movie has been repackaged into a PG or
this wicked novel has been repackaged
into a PG movie The highly inappropriate
adult book has been packaged with a
cover of the new PG movie and now kids
that love the movie are going to want to
read the book and the parents aren't
going to read this huge novel to see if
there's anything inappropriate in it
they're like well the movie was fine the
book's probably okay too
right the sun says no fairy tale priests
roasted on spit and eaten date rape
drugs and sex acts with
tiger The Twisted non-pg Tail behind hit
Wicked shockingly the main character's
mum considers killing her own child and
enters into a thruple
do you know what that is a sexual event
with three people that's in the book
that these children are going to be
reading
soon let me show you what this article
says this is what's in the book but
behind the massively popular movie
musical is a dark and
disturbingly novel is a dark and
disturbingly novel that will shock
Millions as it includes rape racism
beastiality cannibalism orgies and even
child murder that's what's in the book
of this movie that everybody's
watching Wicked the untold story of The
Witches of Oz was first published in
1995 by Gregory Maguire but it wasn't
until eight years later that it was
given a major overhaul to become the
palatable musical which launched on
Broadway however after after reading the
book The Sun can this this article the
sun can reveal all the shocking twists
and turns that have been all but
airbrushed out of the squeaky clean
theater and cinematic
versions it stars pop Sensations Ariana
Grande and British actress Cynthia
iro and has been given a PG rating
citing only mild threat and
discrimination that's what I forgot to
mention to this whole movie about the
wizard being against the witch was
wrapped up in
racism the wizard is a racist apparently
in
this and it is already proving to be a
blockbuster smash taking almost double
the takings of Gladiator 2 wow at the US
box office after they were both released
in the US on
Friday the novel was conceived as a
prequel to The 1939 film The Wizard of
Oz which is a firm family favorite but
the book is anything but one tick tocker
who recently read the
book said trigger warning for everything
if you can think of it it's in here
that's pretty disturbing my main thing
is it's not for kids it really truly not
for children it's really truly not for
children the musical is completely fine
for kids I would not say this book is at
all it centers around Cynthia character
alphaba named after the initials of the
wonderful Wizard of Oz author whose mere
interest entrance into the book is
steeped in
Scandal while the movie suggests her
green skin color as a result of her mom
drinking green alcohol before sex the
original reason is far darker instead
alphaba alaba's mother Melina Molina or
whatever it is is given a green date
rape substance and is sexually assaulted
by a
stranger now if the Wicked Witch's
mother was given this drug and taken
advantage of remember who her father is
her father is the wizard who is God so
this is how God is in this movie or in
this
play once she is born her mom hates her
so much that she has numerous thoughts
of murdering her and spends her years
abusing and neglecting her at one point
she tells her baby shall we go for a
walk by the edge of the lake today and
maybe you'll drown maybe we'll go out in
a boat and tip and tip over even the
midwives Who deliver the TT and
discuss at length whether she is a
hermaphrodite are disgusted by her and
speak about killing her before the baby
bites one of their fingers off
cannibalism and sex clubs in a strange
twist her mom has another affair so
this this book is full of this Affairs
and cannibalism all this stuff her mom
has another affair with a man who
eventually forms a truple with her and
her Min Minister husband who's who's mom
and her that's mom and daughter correct
if I'm reading this correctly but even
away from the main plot there are a slew
of offensive and shocking scenes I would
say within the first 10 or
20% my jaw was on the floor multiple
times I wasn't expecting it to be so
graphic in the first few pages a
religious minister is skewed cooked and
spit cooked on a spit roast and
eaten are you kidding me then in
descriptions too explicit to detail and
mother and daughter are described having
sex with a man at the same time in a
bizarre puppet show this is the story of
wicked are you hearing this a mother and
daughter and a minister right did I read
that right mother and daughter are
described with a man okay a mother and
daughter and a
man later another character is explained
as having skin the color of you know
what in a vile racist remark like the
musical and film much of the story
happens when Alaba has grown up has
grown up and blah blah blah it says in
the movie they're taken to like a tame
dance place but in the book it was a
BDSM club uh in one passage a dwarf is
strapped to a tiger while it performs a
sex act on a naked woman as people sit
around and
watch are you kidding me this is the
most sadistic satanic
disgusting script in history and now is
a PG movie for your children to watch
and entice into reading the book this is
where we're at in society
today I don't even know what the rest of
it says it's just talking about the the
shocking of the book when people are
reading this and they're saying uh they
have sympathy with the writers who had
to make a script like this palatable for
a a musical and a movie and I just can't
believe that this is where we're at that
we are in the days of Sodom and Gomorrah
we are in the days of Noah there's no
doubt about it
can you believe that we are in the last
days I believe it with all my
heart movies and shows and all kinds of
things used to be so sugarcoated that
you looked like a conspiracy theorist if
you picked it apart and saw the message
well now Satan doesn't even have to hide
he's got shows like the seven deadly
sins who fight against the Ten
Commandments
Lucifer games like
Diablo and a movie called Wicked that's
PG rated and fans are going to be
wearing the word Wicked on their shirt
as they glorify the uniting of Good and
Evil pink and green coming together in a
divine feminine green
movement about a defiant Rebellion
against God and His
government if this made sense to you
please tell me if if you think I'm
stretching or reaching please tell me I
want to know your thoughts because this
blew my mind I had no idea nobody else
is talking about this yes there's people
saying this is witchcraft is pushing a
lgbtq movement I never saw this in any
video this was simply coming from some
things I was stumbling upon uh on
articles and stuff if you were blessed
by this video or if it was eye opening
please give it a thumbs up it really
helps the algorithm helps this message
get out to other people that need to see
this message before their kids go and
watch this movie and especially before
they read the
book if you're new to this channel click
subscribe if you think that this is an
important message please share it with
family and friends we love you we thank
you we can't do this without you we'll
see you next time on candid truth if you
would like to support this ministry you
can do so by going to candid truth.org
there you'll find cash app link you'll
find vinmo you'll find zel you can even
give monthly or one time through PayPal
if you like cool t-shirts we have a shop
where you can find cool scripture shirts
and even shirts that say it's cool to
use your brain it's cool to think in a
world that pushes The Narrative that you
don't want to be a nerd and shoved in
the locker you don't want to be the
smart guy just go with the flow just do
what everybody else is doing be a sheep
I'm wearing one of the shirts right now
be cool use your brain I hope you guys
like it I hope you guys are liking the
content that we're putting out here if
you have a suggestion please put it in
the comments we want to hear from you
and again we love you we thank you we
can't do this without you and we'll see
you next time on candid truth